[Music]
so
tell us a little bit about your gut
again oh it's uh
ak-47 uh where'd you got it out tonight
they don't let us march in the streets
anymore so gotta practice some
some of our rights
do you feel like you'll need to use it
no
i think the uh
i think all the people that hate us and
you know want to say [ __ ] to us
too big of a [ __ ] to stop and
actually do anything about
roommate got arrested and they stopped
letting us march anywhere so
start caring
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen we are
live it is a monday
he ain't here no more by the way that
guy just saw him here
you know the guy that was wearing the
ak-47 he
he's he you came for christmas for
yeah he's he's he's dead or dead indoor
nelly
you're allowed ahead you're allowed to
carry uh your weapon in austin texas
you're allowed to walk around with it
uh what you're not allowed to do is to
brandish your weapon
and apparently that is what he did at a
motorist that was uh driving down the
road
coming at these protesters i don't care
if you're in the road
there are laws that says that you're not
allowed to actually be in the road
but you were in the road the car coming
down branch your weapon to the car
a guy in a car's got a gun you're dead
ladies and gentlemen we are broadcasting
on facebook youtube
periscope parlor cloud hub rt
uh oh my beautiful miss leah
bella i like your hair
looking good looking good styling
i gotta get up i gotta give a shout out
to my barber my barber watches the show
eda and um i went in there over the
weekend
and she told she told me that she
watched the show
she loves leah she does oh she
she loves she's sweet but you know she
was like
i'm watching you and you wearing all
these hats covering up
all that hair as hers and i'm like when
are you gonna bring your butt in here
and get your haircut
that's what she said too so you know i i
kind of
i kind of uh feel i kind of feel good
about that but um
thank you eda for taking care
and i'll be in there in two weeks
because i'm going on vacation so you
know i'll be right back in there
uh and um thank you for everything
uh did y'all want to give any shout outs
before we get ready to go
hey guys
[Laughter]
all right everybody everybody there uh
over in twitter land
uh shout out to all y'all jump over to
uh patreon.com
wd show yeah i love it i love it
all right um can anyone tell us
more about the white civil war right
you know what let me start this by
saying
what's happening in portland what's
happening in chad what's happening in
chop
has nothing to do with black lives
period i tweeted
out before and i'm gonna say it until my
whole
uh in into my existence is gone
off this earth everything that you're
seeing right now
is these these th these these crazy
liberals
using black people to destroy what uh
using
uh um uh yeah using black people to
destroy
their city yep it's it's it's that easy
and there i mean because if you look at
these crowds man
it's basically a whole lot of white
liberals
and just destroying everything but using
black lives matter boom clap boom
[Music]
you you're putting it on us
you putting all this destruction on us
and making everybody across the whole
world
slam us well you know black lives
black people aimed it hey but most of
the destruction is coming at the hands
of
a lot of these crazy kids and i heard
they're actually
going to continue to do this they want
to infiltrate more states
and their plan is to burn down all the
pooling
uh anywhere you can vote
they're trying to get all where it has
to be the mail and voting
and they're going to burn down any you
can vote that's what they're trying to
do
i kind of felt ryan i kind of felt uh um
i kind of felt that last week when we
were talking to some of our guests i was
like
um they're trying to push this all the
way up into the election
so yeah so it makes people afraid
to go to the polling stations yes and
then they can't vote
and that's a that's their so-called way
of
stopping president trump from from being
reelected right because that's all
they've got they've got nothing we see
joe biden
remember a week ago on sunday with chris
wallace donald trump did an interview
don't like chris wallace chris wallace
has slipped off the deep end
you know joe biden was supposed to have
an interview with chris wallace this
sunday
yeah he declined uh they're not going to
do it he can't
the democrats have absolutely nothing
but if they divide this country in half
if they burn it down
they feel like they have a chance to win
and somebody over on periscope said
don't forget to talk about
nlac apparently something went down in
kentucky
three black militia members injured in
negligent gun discharge
guys if you're out there walking around
with a rifle and it's loaded
there's something really wrong with you
yeah yeah and
and now i mean joe biden is calling them
peaceful protesters
well the the guy the guy that we just
showed earlier
to start the show he walked up to the
wrong car
yeah again yeah he walked up to the
and met his maker okay
and then and and then on top of that
we we have these peaceful protesters
just walking up to people in their car
and pointing guns at them
[Applause]
what's going on there is no way my life
is being threatened
boom you're dead nobody ever points a
gun at me
not for very long hell no
yeah i uh i heard that ammo is selling
out
i know around where i live in order to
get ammo at the gun store you have to be
purchasing a gun now
you cannot just buy ammo because they're
selling out so quickly
um because people are trying to protect
themselves
you know i had the strangest
conversation yesterday i had a friend
over yesterday
and i had the most strange conversation
uh she came over for the super bowl last
year with me
and out of nowhere i said to her well we
were talking about terrorist attacks and
things like that and i said to her
that i don't think we'll have a
terrorist attack instead it'll be in a
form of a bio weapon it'll be a virus
and then when she came over yesterday
she brought that up to me and said you
remember you saying that i always tell
people that you said that to me and then
this happened
and i but that wasn't the strange part
the strange part was she asked me
well what do we do like if people start
to take over even these small towns
and i literally had to say to her okay
you know we live on a mountain we have
enough food and water and ammo to last
us a year
you just bring you and your son and you
get here and it was such an
it was such a bone chilling conversation
to have
i never thought that i would have to
have that conversation but here we are
and and she's like okay so this is where
i'm coming if if things go
haywire but it's the conversations you
have to have now you have to you have to
have your guns and you have to be ready
for anything
we recorder says uh can i ask what do
you think about the army
taking people we see that here but is
that happening
well the army isn't the army's not
taking anybody
no it's not no are they talking about
how supposedly the army went in and
kidnapped
people from portland that were
protesting is that what they're saying i
don't i
i didn't see nothing cause that's not
what happened what's happening
the federal government has the right to
protect
federal property period in
in stop that's it there's nothing that's
it
people don't get that no no you're right
if you if you want to buck up against
the federal government i mean
yup most of these people just trash in
the states
i mean i'm starting to wonder if this is
the new norm
brian is i mean seriously is this the
new norm what's going on
where's what what we're talking about
six weeks seven weeks eight weeks
of straight of this portland stuff 57
days
yeah 57 days 57 days of this
and you're trying to tell me that the
state isn't strong enough
they don't want to do anything right
right we have a uh
ex uh well it's a marine veteran that
lives
in portland and his views are that he's
hanging out with
uh the peaceful protesters uh he wrote
uh
back to us kind of telling us everything
that went down he's so fed up he's fed
up with facebook he's fed up with
everything
but in portland i believe it was friday
friday night
that it went down he was there with his
wife and kids
he claims that the local police
uh drew first blood uh started
but the protesters that were armed
went all in and then everybody got
involved
and then it was a mess a hot mess and
for those of you saying that the
government or that the police or that
anybody
is using too much force i'm gonna tell
you right now
they ain't using enough because they
ain't stopping this
right i agree so there's people on the
fence there are some people saying
that trump needs to go in you know and
do more
and there's some people who says who
cares let portland burn
what do you guys think look i tweeted
out something
and i want to throw it to y'all because
i'm serious
in watching as a matter of fact hold on
hold on yeah i mean you know
i bro i brought proof i bought proof
because you know i'm i'm i'm tired
okay i tell you what because on the
other side of that fence is federal
troops right or federal agents
if if i'm in charge i'm talking about
state
if i'm in charge remove all law
remove all law enforcement well what are
you saying
remove all law enforcement and put them
around the border of the state
oh stop these jokers from coming in
there were two people
arrested that were from wisconsin that
were up there or
leave it you wanted to be back you want
to destroy the state
you you wanted lawlessness fine have it
but guess what you ain't leaving
you ain't leaving and no federal funds
are coming in
so you want it you got it you take it
beat your head in it for all you want to
be true because you have to y'all broke
it for that mess or
y'all are allowing that message 57 days
is what you said
57 days yeah 57 days it's not going to
stop for another 100 days because this
is political it's no longer about black
lives matter it is political
this is to try to overthrow this is to
try to get trump out of there and
they're going to do anything and
everything they can
they're that desperate because they know
if he gets back in the democrats are
ruined
they're ruined the peaceful citizens of
portland the peaceful citizens of
portland you all got to contact your
mayor you all got to contact the
governor you
all got to start flooding the phone
lines with that mayor
you know that mayor you know here's the
problem though
you're talking about the people of
portland okay the citizens of portland
this is i know people in portland i have
family and i have friends
okay so i message a friend last night
and send them a picture of portland
covered in spray paint and said to them
so was this spray paint always there or
did the rioters do it
okay this is the response i got
the protesters did that not the rioters
these people aren't riding they are
protesting most of them peacefully
again that's what i got back again
anytime you deface public property
that's not peaceful
i said i've seen protests at peaceful
protests and this is not peaceful what
the rest of america is seeing
they don't find comfort in this how is
this peaceful
how is this peaceful it's not
and the majority of those who lived in
during nazi germany the majority of
citizens were peaceful
it was the ones that were vile and
violent
that caused all the destruction so then
they say
we wanted to go out to the rights to see
if the media was telling the truth or
portraying portland in the wrong way
okay
and i said okay okay so what did you do
they said well we went out and saw that
it was peaceful protesting
i said so then you admit the right that
the media
lies to make trump look bad well no i
didn't
this is coming from someone who's got
gender no no i didn't admit that the
media lies to make trump look bad i said
oh so then you admit that these are not
peaceful protests and the feds
then are doing the correct thing well no
i didn't say that either i said well you
don't have a you don't that's your only
two options
is the media lying and making trump look
bad or is trump doing the right thing
because it's not peaceful protest
they couldn't answer it because it
doesn't fit their narrative you know
what that's the train of thought going
on in portland
not for anybody i'm not going to speak
for everybody but well
that train of thought is coming from the
penguin himself it is true there's
violence across the whole country do you
just about that
from antifa that's happening in portland
right now that's right
that's a myth that's being spread only
in washington d.c about antifa in
portland
yes sir there's there's videos
everywhere online there's fires and
riots they're
throwing fireworks at uh federal
officers dhs is there
look online it gets crazy mr nadler
wow so
he thinks it's fake news antique is a
myth yeah antifa is a myth in portland
meanwhile the whole city is on fire and
they're trying to bring down the
courthouse
but you know what
the penguin he even waddles like i know
i know the penguin man it's straight up
that's danny devito
that's danny devito right there more
people in portland believe in the loch
ness monster than they do antifa
and we've actually seen antifa so what
does that tell you
well that's good i like that it's true
and that's the most screwed up part
about it these people are using
power like literally commercial grade
fireworks
they're using power tools yeah
i mean this is something all the purge
yeah they're using a circular saw to cut
the steel
um and if you didn't for your friends
and family
or for anybody out there if you didn't
stay past ten o'clock
and you didn't get into the one o'clock
two o'clock hour
in the am you didn't see nothing
during the day peaceful 10 11 12
midnight witching
oh oh they go nuts
go ahead i'm sorry i was just no i was
just saying they have baseball bats
power tools
they have fireworks they have ammunition
i mean this is the real deal
and people have to start taking it
seriously the laser lights
now i was informed that the red laser
light
which i have a laser pointer that will
temporarily uh keep you from being able
to see very well
but the green one that they were using
that will permanently blind you
mm-hmm here they're waving it
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
this is pissing me off now this is
really pissing me off
because they shouldn't they should not
be allowed to do this
and the mayor the governor is allowing
this to happen
the mayor the governor is allowing this
crap to happen
there are federal officials inside that
building
law enforcement is inside the building
okay believe it or not they are inside
the building and they
i don't know whether y'all have seen
these videos or not but they keep giving
them
verbal warnings now i i mean honestly
really i don't care if they get their
ass whacked i really remember
no not at all i'm i'm talking about
these rioters and pro
and enter i don't care to get their ass
back as a matter of fact i i will grab
me a box of popcorn
and uh and i'll sit and watch it and sit
down there and laugh my ass off
because this i mean if if this is
allowed to happen
or continue it's gonna spread
ladies and gentlemen is going to spread
that way
it happens in america when when um
when uh occupy leah when occupied wall
street went down
that that spread it's bread like cancer
but when you have the representatives in
oregon like that one guy earl i can't
think of his name he's a democrat though
he said on the house floor that portland
is not out of control
and yeah there are some people who have
strong feelings that are acting out
are right there
and when we're talking about the high
grade fireworks we're talking about the
big giant
boomers they'll blow your hand off
they'll blow
your hormones yeah that's what we're
talking and they're shooting them at the
co-ops
yeah i i just so there was one guy that
was uh
inside that building that tweeted out
and had a thread on twitter about his
experience being in there
he said it was a war zone throughout the
night he said it was unbelievable
[Music]
they are adapting ladies and gentlemen
they are
adapting to the tear gas and all the
other stuff
because because the federal agents can't
do bali harm so they are adapting with
these umbrellas and adapting with these
space masks and adapting
with all these other things and they're
continuing to push back
on the police now the the um
the the barriers that they put up now
those videos show that the barriers were
taken down but when the barriers were
put up
they were throwing molotov cocktails
over the barriers
at the people that was in i that was on
the other side of the fence
[Music]
yes
oh
[Music]
that area did you saw those federer
officers
that's almost like like like uh like a
fenced-in playground area and the
and and they're just throwing things on
the inside
you know who can stop this the mayor
or the governor they don't want to they
don't
call the national guard they don't want
to they don't want this violence to stop
right they don't it doesn't stop until
after november
and we talk about texas yeah we talked
about texas already
la la had riots too
and then ladies and gentlemen listen if
if i was if i was mayor or if i were
governor
i would have shut this crap down a long
time ago i would have
and speak softly but carry a big damn
stick you got to
yeah you and oh my rights well guess
what
your rights doesn't give you the right
to destroy
you can say whatever the hell you want
to then your first amendment right
is is is verbally it it doesn't give you
the option to destroy when you start
destroying
there's some consequences to that all
right there's some consequences
and some of these people are all talk
they're all talk they're all big um
billy badass
but when these of when these officials
put them down on their face
i thought i had that um
i'm unsure why this is happening
nice
and you're gonna do this to me are you
serious what did i do i did nothing
[Music]
you were just you know
right you in a wrong damn place at the
wrong damn time
and it reminds me when uh cnn's cuomo
said
since when does it say in the
constitution and peaceful protests you
can't get
well if you read it word for word it
does assembly a peaceful assembly
do you see how she tries to work on your
emotions that's what they're about to do
oh but i'm a nice woman you know how
like the democrats name all these stupid
bills after
everything that makes your hearts you
know tug well that's what she's trying
to do
right and that's what they were taught
to do uh you know work on your emotions
and it's just pathetic
marian on periscope said she was just
out for a walk
oh accused what when
that would is that what uh hillary
clinton said about benghazi
it's just a bunch of guys out for a walk
yeah she said what difference does it
make
right water cannons they need to do
something
sound cannons water cannons what what
real cannons i don't care
i don't i don't care i mean water
cannons would be best you clean that
place up
yeah yeah somebody said turn off their
cell phones and they'll all go home
yeah yep you just scramble their cell
phones they're done
because then nobody sees it they want
and we murdered people we did it every
day
if your generation doesn't know that you
don't know that
so that's why this vietnam veteran
combat medic who took
injured and dead soldiers off the
helicopters this is why i didn't
[Music]
defend my country and then when i got to
vietnam
we committed atrocities we committed
atrocities
every single day when i was in vietnam
i took an oath to defend this government
and when i got to vietnam
we committed atrocities i stood next to
a ditch
in vietnam and we murdered 170
vietnamese people and you guys don't
know that
[Music]
so are you all right well that was a
direct spray
whoa so what is your name
boy he got me right
[Music]
you guys have anything else there's
was that john kerry
john kerry was in vietnam at least i was
told he was in vietnam
threw his medals over the white house
yeah yeah
all because they want to get trump out
they're all billy bad ass
until the consequence is coming because
i never
direct him
it was a lot yeah
he kind of reminded me of a doc on back
to the future he kind of looked like him
do you remember
doc doc that's the first time i was like
it kind of looks like dog
that's direct he got trapped right there
yeah but did you hear him at the end he
said somebody needs to get this on tape
they want all videos to go out and say
look look look at what we're suffering
through
you know what we did we did have uh
oh yeah oh now again uh ladies and
gentlemen
they're they're peaceful protesters so
when you hear the police telling them
what to do
you would expect peaceful protesters you
expect them yeah
fine but you know we'll go ahead and do
this yeah i know this weekend brought a
lot of videos
[Applause]
first off i ain't i ain't helping you
out
let me stop then if you go
if you're gonna go after the police if
you gonna hit the police
expect your ass to get waxed
yeah yeah you're going down i mean
you might have broken bones crush go
whatever
but you don't do that to a police
that is trying to protect or trying to
to to to uh to to to follow orders
and clean up the area or at least make
the area safe
this guy ran right into i mean not the
police on the ground
dude there there is nothing good that's
gonna come from that
[Applause]
right
if i told you to move if i told y'all to
move back move back
don't keep rushing at me because then
i'm gonna have to put a hurt on you
move back yep they have no respect what
did those girls and moms shorts that
they was gonna
yeah ain't no police out there serving
tea and biscuits nobody serving cinnamon
rolls
this is not that kind of party okay if
the police tell
you to move your ass back move your ass
back it's better
to move back and stand on stand on the
sidewalk
and and yell didn't have your face
planted
in the cement with a knee on your neck
and and then you claim you can't breathe
okay
so you kind of caused that on yourself
and that one got wrapped up in that bike
rack
i had enjoyment watching that when i
first saw that i was like ooh
that's what needs to happen
[Laughter]
my phone kind of locked up when she was
bent over it kind of like
and i like oh man that's got to hurt
but there's so there's so there's such
an insidious
message behind this there's so much more
than just the riots i mean if we look
deeper
because what we see at face value are
riots but what's going on behind that
is so much more yeah so much more
what um as a veteran and brian as
veterans
uh over the last couple days we've been
seeing
vets so-called vets i don't know if
they're vets they could be actors i
don't know
but claim yeah
and even if i do say dd214 uh john
kerry's got one so i'm not
i'm here to tell you all vets ain't just
because they say they vet
a good bet you know back up hold on i
agree
uh i don't enjoy watching violence for
the record i do though enjoy watching
the police tell people
to get back and then them get in trouble
for it because that's what needs to
happen
or it's gonna take over the whole
country if you don't have some type of
law order
end of story uh our our guest coming
on has been on the show before has been
on for a while but she's been busy she's
been
uh she's been doing a lot of
uh major as a matter of fact from the
last time that
i that she was on the show and last time
i saw her she
she's uh she her her her role has
exploded
i mean and and that's why we like to
bring
people on that just aren't sitting on
the sidelines and yelling
meaning people that are sitting on
twitter introversion happened this
should happen
she went out and she did something
especially for the veterans that
really need help now i want to see what
she has to say about those veterans
that uh that are out there in portland
but uh i want to hear more about what
she's doing for veterans
and maybe maybe um maybe she can respond
to this
and we murdered him we did it every day
your generation doesn't know that you
don't know that
so that's why this vietnam veteran
combat medic
who took kindergarten dead soldiers off
the helicopters
this is why
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen coming to the stage
friend of mine friend of the show uh
code of vets
at hi wayne if if if you're watching
this right now make sure you're
following her on twitter
what's up gretchen how are you i am
great how are you brother long time no
see
long time long time but yeah it's been a
while
oh yeah yeah we've exploded
[Music]
hi leah yeah leah and brian
brian you know yes i know brian hi leah
it's nice to meet you hi
nice to meet you so we had
tell me tell me about what's going on
with codabetz and
uh how did you start it for those that
don't know and um how how are things
moving along right now well we're moving
along at warp speed
codovets we started out as a twitter
page in honor of my dad
i just saw that vietnam veteran my dad
was a vietnam veteran
he lost his battle with ptsd back in
and dad's life mattered wayne and i
wanted to do something to make sure that
he wasn't forgotten
and that his life of service and death
wasn't in vain and
i started code events and it just really
resonated with the veteran community
because
it's not about a paycheck it's not about
anybody there's no hidden agenda it's
simple it's grassroots
it's simply about veterans taking care
of veterans and
we're very effective we've got a great
process in place
last year was a huge learning curve for
us this year we're we're on it we've got
a system in place that's effective
efficient and we raised 791 000
last year wayne and right now we've
we're well over 800 we'll be surpassing
a million dollars this year
with a one percent operating cost wow
that's incredible for a non-profit to be
able to say that i i've got to give
huge props to you and and the
organization that
you started congratulations absolutely
i can't hear brian oh no
thumbs up i have no i i have sound with
wayne and with leah but not with brian
okay yes i can yeah i can't let me um
let me bring let me bring brian back
brian yeah there we go
i just wanted to give you props for the
organization that you created
absolutely um uh god bless you and god
bless everything that you do
uh you know we've had you over there at
the american priorities conference
just talking about the organization and
getting the word out
um i know 22 veterans take their lives
every day and that's something that
absolutely has to be addressed that
i haven't seen addressed uh in past
administrations
it it's it's it's a crisis in our nation
that we're really not focusing on
right now this year's a political cycle
and everything is hyper
sensitive we are all hyper focused on
the election because our country's in
total chaos right now
that i was just watching your video
clips wayne i this doesn't even look
like our american laura
it breaks my heart i literally am
fighting back tears when i watch these
videos
uh time after time i have a difficult
time because we've served
we've worn that uniform i've served
overseas i know what it's like to look
at a
country from a different lens when you
have
those years in service it just gives you
a different perspective
and to see fellow brothers and sisters
in arms out there and again we don't
even know if they truly are
veterans i don't know um but there are
bad apples in every bunch just like in
the law enforcement community i believe
there's bad apples there but individuals
not systemic
same thing with the veteran community
generally speaking we are
a cohesive unit we are
constitutionalists
and we do not condone this chaos or
anarchy that is rising up and spreading
throughout our country
so this wall of vets i have a lot of
questions about them
i don't even know if they're truly our
vets and and if they are
they've gone astray from from their oath
and i do not i do
i don't support that at all whatsoever i
support what the president is trying to
do
and that's trying to bring in federal
law enforcement to stop this and he's
his hands are kind of tied we're all
watching it from the sidelines and i
i'm ready for the veterans to get
involved i'm fired up i'm furious about
this violence this is senseless and it
is not
this is anti-american this is anarchy uh
and i feel like more of us need to be
speaking out about it wayne
this is these are scary times that we're
looking at that we're facing
yes it sure is hey and i want to ask you
actually a question before you came the
show i was thinking about this
and i just want to get your input on it
the coronavirus obviously has taken a
toll
on everybody financially and mentally
but it had to have hit really hard with
the veterans
struggling are you seeing that ten times
oh my gosh we are swimming in battles
right now the numbers are staggering
it's it's catastrophic what we're
dealing with and it's
it's a great point that you brought up
this hits the veteran community
on such an intimate level because a lot
of them are struggling with ptsd with
tbi with other issues that they bring
back
after service and to add this on their
plate of shutting them down not allowing
them to go to work or earn a
paycheck keeping them in their homes
this this is
not healthy for any human being or or
american but especially our veterans we
have seen an
uptick in depression and suicidal
ideation and in suicide itself we are at
more than 22 a day
uh my most recent dm was two days ago
from a marine who said gretchen i almost
ate my gun last night he called the va
hotline
he and it just it was a very personal
message i'm not going to go into detail
but it
he said i'm just done he said i can't
handle the chaos in our country he said
i've served in war-torn countries
and what we're seeing now on our own
soil that's why we went served overseas
to make sure this wouldn't happen
and for americans to be doing it on top
of it it's a
it's just a double blow for veterans so
not only are they
struggling financially because they have
they're not all back to work yet or some
are still waiting on unemployment 15
16 weeks later but they're dealing with
the chaos
uh and it's it's just almost too much
for them we've never seen anything like
it we are swamped we are working 24
7. wow you know um president trump has
uh
passed signed executive
legislation for veterans uh
what is your take on what he has done
and what needs to be done uh
when president trump is reelected
well the mission act there's a lot of
good pieces of legislation in there the
point
the problem is is the oversight wayne
it's such a large
bureaucracy that when you do when you do
this mass
changes of the laws with the va
specifically you know with taking care
of
our vets their medical care their
benefits who's overseeing that
i feel like this money that's being
shoveled out to
the va it's being mismanaged and it's
not getting into the hands where we're
seeing it direct
the ground we deal with veterans on a
one-on-one basis and
i mean now our you know we've got a
pretty darn good org
now and we're we're helping hundreds if
not thousands of veterans now
so we're not seeing the funding trickle
down the way it should it's getting lost
in these contractors they end up getting
all of this funding then by the time it
hits
our level it's pennies on the dollar and
you can't do much with that
so with the community care we're still
seeing uh doctors not wanting to take
veterans because they're not getting
paid in a timely manner who is
overseeing that money
those funds you're talking about
millions and millions and millions of
dollars
so what why are vet's bills not being
paid that and so
just that in itself are and again
prescriptions is another huge issue we
have found as we're digging more and
more into this
our veterans have heart medication
diabetics you name it and
sometimes they're waiting two and three
weeks for their refill that's insane
that's not that doesn't work you know no
no
my cousin's a marine marine veteran and
he went to a hospital because there
wasn't
anywhere to go nearby for an emergency
situation
uh the the va came to him to the
hospital and said oh yeah you're good to
go
and they did all the paperwork or
whatnot and about six months later
uh some technicality of some sorts
came up and said no we're not paying for
it at all and
apparently the time had run out for him
to
object to it and and this and that and
whatever so now
the what he thought was going to be
taken care of by the va
now you know i think it was like 20 30
that is now he was told to go for an
emergency and now
30 000 in debt yeah it's
there's so much work to do and thank god
for president trump because he actually
embraces the military and better
community and loves and and loves
because he knows
how important we are we are the backbone
of our country we would not have a
nation without the men and women
who've put the uniform on or have it on
right now his heart is in the right
place
once you know once he you know gets his
people in place and
he passed that mission act now it's on
the va to implement it properly
and that's where you run into issues
it's massive you know there's not over 9
million veterans
that filter through that the va
and it's just there's there's going to
be a lot of
failures a lot of people who fall
through the cracks and i don't even know
if we'll ever have a perfect va
but we we sure need to talk about it and
work on it and i
you know i definitely would like to have
a line of community communication reopen
back up with the va headquarters i did
for a short period of time
but they need to hear us at the
grassroots level what the real
day-to-day issues are because that's
where i feel like we can find the most
uh there's the most room for improvement
because we can give them ideas
actually practical that you know you can
put in place my
my partner dr cindy walter has her phd
in public health
oh my gosh wayne uh she the woman is
brilliant she would be such a huge
asset to the va right now we we just
they need common sense voices
they need to know what is actually going
to work for our vets because once they
put these mass
laws into place that are like 35 30 000
miles above
you know flying over the veterans
sometimes they're not practical
you know that sometimes the ivory tower
doesn't meet up with
everyday life how
how are the um how are the veterans that
are getting help are they uh
are they in turn joining and helping out
um uh how is the response
from them and uh
there are probably some out there that
probably need a little bit more help
than others
yes how are you working that we
we actually have got a team in place now
across the country and so my partner
again cindy
she's the one who kind of handles she
coordinates all the cases and forms them
out and keeps the simple she'll send out
the simple ones to our team then she'll
keep the complex the homelessness cases
the ones that are you know it's going to
take sometimes we've walked with
veterans for a year and a half two years
because they're in such difficult spaces
when you're homeless it is not easy to
just
break out of that cycle it's difficult
and you're at a higher risk
of becoming homeless again so we walk
with these guys for a very long time we
took 52 veterans off the street last
year
and a lot of them are still we're still
monitoring and we're kind of advocating
for them and
to make sure they don't you know they
they don't break that cycle
again because once we take a hold of
them they they become our family
you know they become part of us and
that's the wayne when we
we don't just help a vet one time a lot
of times they would be a particular vet
so you'll see on twitter
when i do a buddy check there's hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of replies and
when two or three or six or seven
veterans are they put a statement out
that they're struggling or
we had a vietnam veterans and i'm
thinking about blowing my brains out
veterans that we have assisted will
swarm that brother-in-law
will surround him and say dm me brother
i've got you i've been there
i've i just sent you my phone number
call me and so we're creating we're
creating this beautiful
informal network across the country
using social
media platforms for something incredibly
powerful we've saved we've saved several
lives and we've changed we've given
second chances at life
and it's growing and growing because it
works and it literally is about us
veterans down here just at the
grassroots level with a heart for each
other
wow i actually have an audience question
for you
a wife a veteran reached out to me and
she wanted to know about support dogs
and she wanted to know your advice if
you've heard any positive feedback with
support dogs and if so
are you able to help them find a support
dog for her husband who's dealing with
uh ptsd right now
actually we do have a couple of uh
nonprofits that we you know we
communicate with do support dogs
support dogs are great i am absolute
they
have they've saved lives um especially
with our vets with ptsd
i am a huge supporter of it and anytime
that i can make a connection i will
and if she's if she can hear me just
fill out a vet and need form on
codabets.com and then that way we can
give you some guidance on where to go
and to get a dog so that's that's
something that we don't personally get
involved with but we can
actually give you guidance to where you
can actually where you'll be able to go
find one and you can get the assistance
that you need
and the dogs are great um very well
trained uh
i'm all for it that's great thank you so
where's the best
best way for people to get a hold of you
contact you and get help is it here yes
there fill out a vet and need form in
the menu just click on the right or
right
right hand corner and you the menu will
will drop down
you'll see the vet and need form it's
very simple fill it out and at the
bottom just let us know exactly what
your specific issue is
and we'll get back to you in 24 to 40
hours and start working
with you to to work through the problem
and see what we can do to give you some
guidance or financial assistance
whatever the case is
and that is codeofbets.com
yes yes.com and your twitter
is yeah at codabets we have a facebook
instagram code events and then we have
recently started the linkedin we've
actually
placed a few dozen veterans with jobs
with employers so we're trying to grow
that as well so we're just trying to hit
all the bases with our vets you know as
they come through whatever issue is
we want to be able to tackle it we've
got a lot of connections and resources
weighing across the country who
work with us behind the scenes because
they see the good work we do
um and they a lot of people jumped over
and said
gretchen whatever i can do for a vet in
my area and those are employers too um
so veterans if you are out of jobs right
now and you want to send us your resume
do it the codabets.gmail.com and i will
see what i can do to connect you with
employers in your local area
that's awesome and how long have you
been doing this uh we had we started
in 17 as a twitter page we became a
non-profit in october of 2018.
i remember that video yeah
yeah wayne's been with yeah he's been
with me from the beginning it's been
awesome
he's watching me from nothing literally
man he was so happy when that letter
came out oh my god
yeah wow look at that look a big old
smile
i know i know it's not easy becoming a
non-profit
it's not it's navigating all the
bureaucracy
yeah i'm learning as i go i've never
been involved in nonprofits never been
an activist or or an advocate and so i
as we grow
i'm learning to grow with it and i think
that's what attracts people too
is that we you know we're not some big
corporation we
this is literally heart-driven and
uh the veterans feel it they and the
donors they trust us because we're
incredibly transparent with our money we
put it out there we put everything out
there for everybody to see
because i want i am a good steward of
the funds and i just want
everybody to know that my heart is in
the right place i do this to honor my
dad i know he's watching me in heaven
and i i want to make him proud so this
this has really grown into
a a a good veteran platform
and we're doing a lot of good stuff
we're getting oh my gosh over a million
dollars this year i'm amazed by it
yes i can i can attest to that you have
been who you
s who you are since i've known you so i
can absolutely attest to that
yep well we're going to keep fighting
for our vets and keep speaking out for
our country you guys do the same thing
oh my gosh wayne you've exploded in
growth too thank you for
your voice um it's rational it's common
sense it's what we need
i i do have some fears about the future
of our country but i have hope
uh because i believe in the american
spirit and i believe in you i believe in
each one of you and um you're making a
difference i monitor i watch
and we all matter um we we need to be
out there fighting for our country and
letting our nation know that hey
uh we've got we've got common sense
americans out there that know that we
need to support and defend the
constitution anarchy is not the way to
go
marxism socialism communism that's not
who we are we're an extraordinary
country and we're worth fighting for
amen
um gretchen i want to have you back on
again i want to see
where you are uh in in a month or so on
uh and whatever help that you need from
us just let us know
and we'll be there and you can contact
me or contact brian
i'll talk to you in dm uh ryan or
or uh brian through text or whatnot so
yeah okay yeah sounds great yeah just
okay
all right i love you guys thank you too
thank you great thank you so much code
of vets ladies and gentlemen
codabets.com
and um you can get out there and and and
sign up if you're a veteran
and you need help connecting that's a
wonderful thing she's
she's saving lives she's changing lives
that's what life is about
yeah she yeah she is so honest
up front oh she i mean she is who she is
you know i mean the way she talks the
way she carries herself the way she
handles herself
and how how she talks about how nice and
helpful that she is to other people that
is
who she's who she is um
they're getting getting back to
portland and what's happening
and i know okay i know y'all are sick of
it
i know y'all are sicker and i know most
of you are sick of it because
the the leaders that be won't do
anything about it
but these people are so
there's a lack of concern for the for
their
the city and the the collateral damage
that
they are bringing up that they
feel that their mind is twisted you know
what i'm saying their mind
their minds
it's like good as evil and evil is good
you know
uh this guy feels that it's his need
to be out there hey why are you out here
why why are you out here i'd prefer not
to be
but someone has to we cannot allow this
kind of injustice to go
unchallenged we cannot allow
intimidation
to succeed we can't let them bully us
off our own streets
as though that's somehow okay
so we have to stand up is this your
first night
oh no and unfortunately i doubt it will
be my last
because well there's a lot that still
needs fixing and until the feds leave
and the police are seriously defunded or
reformed
our job isn't done are you staying even
at this tear gas
i have before i don't like it believe me
there are things i would rather be doing
tonight
but justice requires people to stand
up
again i told you i told you that their
minds
are so worth they they aren't going to
stop until the feds leave
and the police are defunded
the movie with the movie with nicholas
cage
and he has a daughter and she
is a freedom fighter an anarchist sorts
of and
she hooks up with this young kid and
they're both young and they're
they've become their own superheroes
taking on crime in the streets
and the kid keeps getting his ass beat
yeah this is what this guy's been
watching he's hot
he's not a superhero he had on an
animatics
mask do you remember the animation
really did your mom say that for you
come on
but um now where are you at now
again i started off saying that what's
happening
in portland doesn't have anything to do
with black people i told you all that
no he said he wants to oh go ahead
because most of the people that you see
that are causing all this damage is
white so what happens
when you get a black american oh no
telling these people to stop what
they're doing
and the moms are going to do that
okay please just give me a chance give
me a chance
where you are don't hit the fence please
give me a chance
all right please i've been out here all
day doing this all right they set it on
the middle
they will not shoot us they will not gas
us if we do not try to breach
if we try to breach they're going to do
whatever they can
to to to keep their people
away from the building i don't want them
to be hurt i don't want you to be hurt
and i definitely don't want to be hurt
okay
[Music]
no you know when this all ends you know
this will all end
when those idiots go home but they're
not going to go
yeah they're allowed to be there and
they're staying they ain't
trying they're not going to go home
until after the election right
right right and that's what is going to
happen
and and and i put out a video this
morning
well i didn't put out a video i shared a
video
because uh a lot of people on our side
keep sharing blacks doing all these
crazy things
but they don't want to share antifa
antivirus situations
i'm i i i see a lot of people i
i see a lot of you that's surprising uh
and and and when i saw this i had to put
it out there bryant
brian sent me the same thing but i'd
already put it out there a couple hours
ago
yeah an hour and a half earlier i missed
it
this one man one man
stood up against all of antifa right
and and timo tried to shut him up
[Applause]
oh
black lives matter
i had to kind of clean that up because
of the end but
yeah i mean he
it he didn't say he was a trump
supporter and you don't have to be a
trump supporter
nope to just have to be an owner of
common sense
there you go yeah there you go
i mean but but did you see those people
just run up
you stop the white people yeah
dressed in all black i mean you can tell
they're being bought and paid for by
soros and pelosi and everybody else
it's getting sick oh and guess what they
didn't hit him
they didn't take him down they didn't
poke him
they didn't touch them right
right anybody else anybody else oh
they would have took down a white person
they've been into your afternoon
man your afternoon to be over
kind of my person he didn't touch him
[Applause]
oh
you know that's what i'm saying it's not
even about that anymore it's about
it's about something deeper it's about
taking over it's about ruining this
country
that would be that wouldn't even be a
split second long
if you point if you went to raise a gun
to me i would shout put it down
if it kept coming up i would fire
immediately
i'm not waiting leah what would your
[Applause]
husband
[Laughter]
isn't her bullet
i don't even care that's just how it
goes you're not going to point a gun
at somebody in a car i mean who do you
think you are
right you know the one guy yeah the one
guy out there in texas died
like raised ak-47 towards the guy stupid
um right a lot of this uh mark
mark levine last night came out with an
incredible explosive groundbreaking
report from stanley kurtz
from um he's an editor
and apparently they have found
that under the obama administration the
affirmatively furthering
fair housing act wow that's a mouthful
affirmatively uh forward furthering fair
housing
uh i'll scope about it later on tonight
there's a whole lot to be said about it
if you didn't see it
last night basically what it was or what
it
was supposed to be was the federal
government
to create a layer between cities
and suburbs to make the suburbs beholden
to the cities
through money hud and and uh
oh and booker locked it all down with
transportation funds saying that your
city don't get no money unless you get
unless you get involved with the way we
got this set up
and now the federal government owns it
oh
that was under barack hussein obama
donald trump
ben carson ben carson why did they hate
that man so much
he found this he found it yeah yeah
and they shut it down completely amazing
shut
it down yep yep
well i can tell you i had to take a
break from watching the portland riots
over the weekend
and a few nights ago so and i don't
watch professional sports i don't i
refuse to but i had to see felchi throw
out that pitch because i just want i was
hoping he would i was hoping he would do
bad
because i can't stand him let me tell
you
that pitch was beautiful it was just
like
god coming down and saying this is what
you get buddy
i loved it it's an example do you see
what china did
it was time china took took that video
and
hazed out the sides put bars on the side
so you couldn't see the ball going off
to the side
well then there you go china him and
buddies
yeah kind of like how he handled the
coronavirus right
yeah exactly that's exactly what i
tweeted out i was like well this is a
perfect interpretation of how he handled
the coronavirus
way off oh
my gracious
so ladies and gentlemen that's that's
our monday
that's our monday and these video and
57 days is what you said i believe that
was last count 57
and we got 99 days till the election
well technically you have 44 days though
until you can start voting
early voting starts in 44 days oh
yeah yep
ladies and gentlemen ride with us all
the way to the election
ride with us uh brian
smith leah bella wayne dupree we're here
uh i gotta get this phone thing
straight so that we can start taking
some phone calls
i want to talk to you guys yeah yeah
yeah um
any last word for it you know what that
sounds so morbid
um any any uh
last things you want to talk about last
thoughts vlog
sounds good there you go last thoughts
yeah
i'll go yeah go to patreon.com forward
slash
wd show and from there you can
get a membership five ten twenty thirty
forty dollars
it helps the show it helps our platform
helps us to get real talk out
and it's important to us so if you can
go to patreon.comwd show take a look at
it see what you can do
and make a decision from there
be man i did not know this we talked
about this before the show rolled and i
am absolutely beside myself that i
usually got my finger on the pulse of
just about everything going on
uh ibuprofen don't do it let's talk
about
that don't do it good yeah i'll talk
about it for a second
so um this hits me pretty hard
uh yesterday my cousin died of
government
and he was only 49 he didn't have
underlying health conditions
um but he did take an ibuprofen and
just about an hour after he took it he
felt cold all over
and he passed out at his home and he
died and from what i'm understanding
right now is
the ibuprofen actually even though
ibuprofen
thins your blood whenever you get
covered 19 it actually somehow thickens
it
and the ibuprofen causes some type of
storm and it can actually throw blood
clots to your heart and that's what
they're thinking happened
but he passed away yesterday only 49
years old he was my closest cousin and
just if you're out there and you get
covered
don't take ibuprofen i'm throwing
ibuprofen out of the house
all together your tylenol take your
tylenol do not and if you have children
who get coveted
don't give them ibuprofen and don't give
them motrin motrin's the same thing
give them tylenol because then they
could have that big multi-faceted effect
or whatever
they're calling mcc or msc um
so please i'm just begging everybody
don't take advil if you get this
don't take ibuprofen
yup my my sister's uh husband as a
matter of fact
was diagnosed with coronavirus but um
uh he he got through um the quarantine
and um from from what we're hearing
if you get it it doesn't
it's not about not having it anymore
because some people
still have it you know you don't just
get rid of it
some people just don't get rid of it so
if you are feeling better and stuff and
okay fine the 14 days of gray your front
you might still have it in your system
so just just just be careful
man i mean you know just be careful out
there and
i i know again i know a lot of people on
our side
um have uh really tried to push that
uh you know having it
versus the deaths um it doesn't add up
but i think i would probably want to be
in a camp
that doesn't have it and because if you
don't have it
you can't die from it even if i mean
even if you know so uh
please take care of yourself out there
and and and leah you say
um vitamins and different things right
yeah they they're saying that uh vitamin
d
is very important during all this and of
course vitamin c but especially vitamin
d can help ward it off
yep there are reports uh larry elder
actually interviewed a lady
that is in the health industry and she's
saying that
that vitamin d and low dose steroids
is something that they've been using
it's been working really really well
[Music]
yeah thank you audience thank you
everybody for your wishes
i appreciate that we have such a great
great audience and we're blessed to have
you and
they they support you so much and
honestly you guys's words mean more than
what you think
so thank you for uh your condolences
appreciate that
yeah so a lot of you uh
we don't get all the comments up on the
thing but we do see them and
we do check them out and we we do thank
you
for um for everything and
uh we will be back tomorrow 12 o'clock
premium eastern standard time
uh as a matter of fact tomorrow for
those that uh are still here
and a great number that is oh yeah
um young man was stabbed by antifa
uh over the weekend and he's gonna be
here
talking about what happened and how he's
recovering
from that and how he's gonna continue
doing what he was doing
and tifa is not going to stop him as a
matter of fact
he might even we might be even
interviewing him from the hospital bed
so
wow i'm not sure uh where he's going to
be but
i did make sure to secure that interview
and bring him on so uh
look forward to that and wayne i do want
to tell you that you do have more
viewers than
uh what biden did mr fox photo just said
that that is true
the last uh little webinar he had i
think he had
29 viewers and like 15 of them were
actually media
26 minutes into it and it was down to
19.
they're gonna have to cheat to win
they're gonna have to cheat the win
they screenshotted their their uh their
phone that they were one of the ones on
the the call twenty they said 26 minutes
ago it started and they're 19 total
watchers 19 right now
for us
yeah yeah because total because totally
right now we
live we have about 1500. so
yeah well biden gets 19 people so
congratulations
y'all are doing it believe me y'all are
doing it so thank you
uh yeah we so we'll be back tomorrow god
willing and um we want to thank
everybody for tuning in
don't forget to check out patreon.com
for slash wd show
keep us moving you wanna you wanna add
another half an hour to the show
add some add some muller to the show
and then we can keep on doing this a
little bit longer
you know what i'm saying huh you know
okay i mean it
yeah if we could done along i could have
told you my joe biden story but we're
gonna have to wait till tomorrow for
that it's a good one
you'll never believe it we'll wait for
tomorrow that's how
that's how we roll so brian out
leah out my name is rain dupree you
are watching the wayne the free show god
[Music]
bless
you